[Music]
in the unicorns in the universe
[Music]
now are you ready
mr coffee
can you leave the light on both
i get a little scared
being false accusing rape
in the dark sometimes
and uh
most men
can't tell that [ __ ] the witch sponge
now as you can probably guess mr coffee
is most certainly gonna fry
and that's only because we outlawed
hanging but six years ago
but he'll still get to enjoy his last
meal of his favorite chatter on this mug
or from this mug
louder with crowded dot com slash mug
club
he likes it
for as much longer as he has
[Music]
hey everybody
aloha i want you to know something
you do not belong in civilized society
and you must be held accountable
we need a nuclear holocaust this week
join us in exploring the land that
helped bring us dwayne the rock johnson
jason momoa amen
and people from samoa
it's a pineapple-loving culture that
only a tropical paradise can offer it is
great to be back in kenya a great place
to call home until you're hit with a
cyclone it's the pacific islands
sorry about that uh the intro there
though the volume was a little bit uh it
was a little blast well the first one
probably blasted their eardrums and then
low and my the thing is because i have
this
welcome
i just felt the safety bin
yakuza casey i just felt it busted my in
my in my aquaman shirt it just broke so
now i'm gonna be oh jeez look this is
where my nipples are off here do we need
some help all right it's cultural
appropriation month scraping the bottom
of the barrel i don't know we've done
all the countries now when you're in
year eight yeah no more interesting
countries so uh you can send in your
costumes to um they send them
in at twitter there token on yep twitter
and instagram twitter askcrowder and on
instagram we'll read them on mug club
yeah we have a lot to get to today hey
look we actually have live exclusive on
the ground uh coverage of the supreme
court they're going to be potentially
releasing decisions today if they don't
they release them tomorrow we might just
come and stream live here so uh that's
always why we recommend that you just
you know set the hit the notification
bell tune in
monday through thursday 10am eastern but
tomorrow may be one of those things we
take a flyer we have people on the
ground gingersnap is there right out in
front of the uh is he out in front of
the supreme court in front of the
capitol right now
they're right next to each other so okay
yeah we'll see we're see we're here
wherever he is safe by the way if you
want you can say this right now the
supreme court has issued a ruling
striking down the concealed carry law oh
wow in new york so we'll get details on
exactly what that means yeah we'll get
to our on the ground uh
we'll get to
that yeah that's a lot of paper yeah
it's a lot of paper and small just so
you know we're not senators we can't
read uh 900 pages in 20 minutes which
they all do before they that's true vote
this looks good to me so we'll be
talking about that uh i don't know if
you know about this but aoc is
complaining about her hundred and
seventy thousand dollar a year salary oh
poor thing so well of course we're not
without we're not without empathy
uh of course child enthusiast ezra
miller is on the run in hawaii but uh
not really for the reasons that you
think so we're talking about all of this
and more here today also the reason for
gas inflation all of these prices uh i
don't know if you heard this former vice
president joe biden tried to say that uh
it was a it was russia ukraine oh really
and then the fed chairman himself said
no it's not no not so much that's that's
not true so uh and of course dave and i
are on tour uh at loud earthquake.com
tour in the fall phoenix houston
charleston west virginia
nashville we added another show because
one is almost sold out red bank new
jersey
and then baltimore
fastest man on his feet thank you dave
for being here ahoy you doing well good
i'm
i'm a weird el pollo yuma louis yes
[Laughter]
troy
and then gerald is here you're uh i
think i get it
you think you understand who i am really
i think i understand yeah i met tom
selleck once yeah i'm a i drive a
ferrari and i'm a pi yes the math
doesn't
yeah it's like every public school
teacher in the film yeah yeah yeah
amazing oh gosh these kids are driving
me nuts i need to go clear my head and
my bends yes i signed some papers over
to uh from my house to him this morning
yes exactly life is good well you did
because you understand it's not his uh
his first rodeo yes
um
and if i sound out it's because i'm sick
today just so you know
one of the babies uh i knew the exact
moment where i felt a slobbery fist
get punched into my mouth it was like
the embalming fluid and dragged me to
hell i'm definitely gonna be sick from
this yes
so now i apologize for the contagion
that's about to spread out through the
uh through the entire studio all right
do we have them on the line yeah we do
okay so actually right now uh they just
released their uh they strike struck
down a new york concealed gun law and
we're seeing if they're going to release
their opinion on dobbs jackson
uh it's time for scotus watch
we have uh gingersnap let's uh let's uh
let's hit
[Music]
all right gingersnap are you there sir
i am here we are in front of the supreme
court right now
and the lady from time magazine's
laughing at me what the hell is going on
here ginger snap
i'm i'm tom selleck today
but yeah i know but i'm not i'm not even
ti no it's the same person it's i'm i'm
i mean i have the hat and everything
dude he's totally stole my deal
no you sell reverse mortgages
that's fine you know what look i'm gonna
play judge here no
we're splitting the baby you have the
reverse mortgage deal and gingersnap has
the the actual cool stuff so ginger snap
he's got the shorts too the people
behind oh my god
you know you didn't have to do that we
didn't need a cowboy shot on you
this is big j journalism
so tell us what's going on down there
they just struck down the concealed
carry law and you're saying the time
magazine lady is is uh has an issue with
you
yeah the time magazine that he's
laughing at me she's very pretty though
so it's okay yeah but yeah they just
struck down the new york carry last so
it looks like the rulings might be over
for today i don't think that they're
going to get to dodge jackson today but
that's not stopping the um
enthusiasm from heating up out here
there was a group of pro-life protesters
too but they were getting kind of shoved
to the back and so they just left um
hopefully we can find one of them to
talk to you later but i think we're
going to try to talk to you um
can you ask one of them what they think
before we get to the roe v wade can you
ask one of them what they think about
the the court striking down the new york
concealed carry law
[Applause]
well you know you know what that's okay
there uh gingersnap ask her because she
seems very concerned about losing uh the
right to abortion which of course is not
what would happen ask her if it's
possible to abort a pot roast
[Laughter]
all right well i don't think she gets
the joke
uh is there anyone else you know who uh
can uh discuss this rationally with you
do you think do you want to try and find
someone
um
boy that is a loaded question if you see
those people out there that's true
she seems sane
they don't like free press there i'm
surprised they don't want to talk with
you i wonder if they're just uh
i mean you seem like the kind of person
they would be fond of you know with a
pedophile stash
all right well gingersnap uh just call
in and we'll check in with you
throughout the show and uh you know let
uh tokonawa know if you find anyone
who's you know worthwhile uh and uh i
won't hold my breath but we'll check in
[Music]
she's a vagina voter oh
she might hit him what does she use she
uses it to pull the lever i mean i don't
know how you fill out a scantron i once
saw one play a harmonica
it's quite a flag
she's got a weapon
you know the only reason she's able to
hold that giant flag is because her at
the fulcrum you know she's a
counterbalance yes
[Laughter]
all right we'll check back in with you
uh uh uh gingersnap yeah that's that's
not at all what i expected ugly angry
primarily white [ __ ] no
not at all now i know if you're
simulating ejaculation if you were
saying why are you doing this this is
below you this is soft first off check
out the studio today second
this is very different from a change my
mind you know i've talked about how you
need to determine yeah you need to be
able to determine the people with whom
you can converse the people who you can
actually with whom you can actually have
a rational conversation and potentially
change their mind and then there are
people who just want to watch the world
burn and you need to make an example of
them those people are silly
someone's saying she say regulate
ejaculation yeah yeah what does that
even mean does that mean she's trying to
say like oh equal
equal and opposite reaction if you're
going to regulate my vagina regulate
ejaculation is that what she's trying to
say i i didn't i don't know that she put
that much thought into it
my body's been doing it on its own and i
think i need to see a doctor yeah
science yeah yeah well that's called uh
auto uh non-erotic
ejaculation
is that what it is yeah it's a problem
oh i thought it was just
they you know what's so funny is these
feminists are like you know if uh if uh
if uh men uh were uh if it was men
having abortions i've heard this actual
argument like you know then you'd get
viagra for free you're like first off
what but i think the point that you're
trying to make is that men are treated
better by the law um men are not
demanding free
taxpayer funded viagra or condoms no no
no we're not now they've tried to argue
that because
yeah they've tried to argue that viagra
since it's covered under certain you
know socialized like whether it's
medicare or medicaid i don't know which
one where sometimes they pay a certain
amount of copay that that's the
equivalent to
abortion and by the way erectile
dysfunction for old people is an actual
medical condition not wanting to have a
child uh through the act of sex that you
chose
is not don't the idea that we now treat
babies as medical conditions yeah well
look giving an old person a boner so
that they don't fall out of bed that's i
mean that's got some value
[Laughter]
you know what i'm rolling out they roll
over
hit it and roll back it's like with my
babies in the crib has a little the
grate that comes up
and you have to put them in a little
swaddle so their foot doesn't get stuck
you have any broken hips that's
prevented it's also
causes skyrocketing stds and old folks
homes but you know what they're almost
in the grave anyway yeah i mean no yeah
that's absolutely true statistically
yeah it's those those old ladies in the
old folks homes they get around i mean
slowly but they get around they do get
yeah
it's good they have walkers and plastic
on the furniture because it's a mess i
just certainly hope that it's one of
those walkers with a handbrake
booty calls have to be made an hour in
advance so they can get there it's just
basic the walker is really just a mobile
liberator yeah they have balls on the
walker and their
chins uh
all right all right no not at all okay
we'll check back in with gingersnap um i
know the the reception there isn't
necessarily the best but uh look this is
one of those things we're on the fly
we're going to see what happens i
expected more people to be honest
yeah yeah no here's the thing it'll be
interesting to see if the media so we'll
let's keep an eye on whether it's cnn
whether it's abc nbc bs if they try and
make it seem as though this was a giant
groundswell remember they tried to do
that with right the [ __ ] march and the
first [ __ ] march was relatively large
but it wasn't nearly as big as the tea
party no one actually understood that
but then when they tried to resurrect it
they tried to do it the next year no one
was there but the media acted as though
it was a repeat so
i'm very curious to see what kind of
coverage this gets on the media if they
try and make it seem like it's this
tremendous ground swell several dozen
protests at the capitol i'm sorry
thousand i mean i'm sorry did i read the
actual number several thousand yeah it
would be more but it's a little rainy
and they didn't want to buy ponchos
right
this one woman was yelling regulate
ejaculation scared everybody off yeah
exactly
what it meant no nobody knew what it
meant we don't think she knew what it
meant uh and then there was a lady with
a giant flag who was a human equivalent
to that duck that dips in the water
yes all right it is cultural
appropriation month so it is time for
pacific islands fact or fiction
[Music]
top-notch baby
by the way i i would look like
anyway these stupid fake muscles in the
suit
those are fake i know i know i would i
would look bigger without the fake
muscles because it wouldn't look like i
have these like these man titties like
real
this
hooves are huge all right so tokenawn
this is where we have to guess which uh
of the following facts are true or false
fact or fiction that's right fact number
one or fiction there are no venomous
snakes or insects in french polynesia
i'm going to say that that is fact
because i i think that's the case in i
know it's in hawaii
yeah there are no venomous snakes or
insects so the insects are not venomous
as well or no insects at all i don't
know i know the snake part so i'm just
going to believe all of it
i'll go with you on that okay what do
you say fact fiction dave i i guess just
uh to take the other side just to make
it interesting but i think you're right
but i'm gonna i'll go i'll say
all right token one all right stephen
and gerald are correct yeah
see i agreed with them but yeah good for
them you just covered all your bases but
then how they all get so bloated yeah
i thought it was like i thought it was
like my girl just a lot of bees it's a
mystery yeah
all right he needs his glasses
not anymore he doesn't broad uh here's
another fact fact of fiction new zealand
is the only nation in the world
that can put hobbits on its currency i
hope that's true
i'm gonna say
fiction
i'm gonna say
fiction as well yeah unless there are
some
hobbits lobbyists i mean look just like
they're probably down there right now at
the white house yeah that's true i just
saw three of them all right sorry i i
took your job from you token now when
you're supposed to read it all right let
me know if it's factual is that fact or
fiction they can what
i hope it's true really gerald is
correct
wow
what a silly place it is that's why i
hoped it was true wow
what a silly silly stupid place you and
pj should go to lunch sometimes yeah
that's peter jackson i didn't know and
by the way someone get him a cup can
someone get him uh a software download
of adobe or final cut yes not every film
has to be four and a half hours yeah
yeah last 30 minutes a lot of hills
there maybe just a little jog before yes
exactly
maybe maybe some interval training yes i
know you're not a star of the movie but
we do have to look at you when you
premiere did you walk up any of the
hills just you know shave
you're a multi-millionaire installed
into the hills one of those electric
seats elevators like in gremlins that
goes up
he just had four pas carry him yeah yeah
it's just elijah wood like oh come on
you can walk the hill yourself he's like
shut up [ __ ] i'm fat let me just go up
and drag he goes down to get his kalachi
all right i'll be up
go do run-through
you were in my girl right that was the
other one right yeah thank you that was
the bad son all right to the next one
fact or fiction number three hawaii was
the 49th state admitted into the union
gerald oh thank you for throwing that at
me i am not 100 sure on this so i will
go true
false is it 50th i was gonna say it's
it's either 49th or 50th it's one of
those two i believe yeah it's 49th or
50th it could have been 48th who knows
who knows uh i'm going to say uh i'm
going to say true i think it's true all
right you guys are
wrong hawaii was the 50th
missed it by that much oh whatever 49th
was alaska yeah yep
by the way the russians really screwed
that up yeah whoops alaska oh yeah
they're like oh we want it back two
cents an acre somebody
there's gold oil and all kinds of fun
stuff yeah bears that eat people we
don't like all right what's the next one
here token factor fiction number four
this sentence writes into real language
naso
why did you sound like a girl well after
knowing what i know about the the new
zealand that they can put hobbits on
their money and dress up as one what you
just said is very stupid i'm gonna say
true i'm going false i feel like that
was contrived yeah i don't know why i
had to do it in that racist jar jar
bank's voice but i'll allow it that's
true uh i'm gonna suck
i'll say i'm gonna go true all right all
right you do that to yourself well i'll
tell you guys why i read it in that
racist character brings voice it's
because jar jar was based on this
language pidgin
really so i guess it wasn't racist it
was just stupid oh wait yes it was just
so much like the real people jar jar was
stupid mesa doing method acting
meet a shitty daniel day luisa
if i drink you're bad a prequel
that's a real thing everybody said how
much they hate it and you're like that's
based on real people
that's their representative's culture
yeah it's great it's like going to some
film building i cannot believe this is
horrible so that's based on the jamaican
bobsled team those are actual human
beings oh that was real wow yeah oh uh i
loved it didn't know i also had no idea
good jar jar there you go token has a
hidden talent all right next one fact or
fiction all right you guys are all tied
up but two weeks okay you left okay so
next question tongans uh consume more
pineapples than any nation in the world
this is your guess is as good as mine
i'm gonna say false i think it's true
you everybody saw the tongan guy at the
olympics
you remember that no oh it made it
pineapples
pineapples yeah it was very very like
ripped and he was just like fully like
did he eat pineapple and i think that
means
he had was this a drink oh wow he just
yeah
he's just reaching he's like you guys
all saw this person right yeah the
questions about eating pineapples gerald
i believe i've made my cake you remember
the muscle man that ate all the
pineapples
but no but he's not even making that
argument he's like he just said you
remember the muscle man
as though that was the last yeah thank
god he doesn't write children's
tales do you know the muffin man done
that's it how else did he get like that
i'm gonna say
i'm gonna say true yeah okay so you
agree well no i don't i don't agree with
what you said yeah
thank god you didn't pass the bar yeah
dave and gerald you're gonna tell me
that you think tongans eat more
pineapples than uh chinese and brazilian
steven got it right
i would have said i i well and china and
brazil are horrible places well that's
true because there's a billion of them i
should have done the math yeah true that
makes way i don't know if it was a
pineapple per muscle man capita that's
true i
all right hey final true or false final
true or false just throw pineapple on
your chinese food you don't even want it
right and then a canadian throws it on
pizza yeah you know it's hawaiian like
what no it's not it's like that's how we
picture hawaii because we can't afford
to go
to the states uh all right final factor
fiction there final one in tagalog
samoan only refers to males females from
the island are called loihi
i'm going to say uh
here's the thing i don't care
so i'll say true true i'm going to say
true because i've never seen a samoan
gale yeah well they're usually uh
devoured and thrown in a cave it's true
yes
if you look at the way those natives in
those polynesians not
brutal well brutal they're on an island
like who's going to come and stop us
right yeah exactly and we're all 900
pounds
and bored yeah
we're large strong and angry yeah
because if they do exist we're just not
wanting them right
thank god they're secluded it's like
samoan jurassic park but with people all
right the only one i've ever seen is
hunter s thompson's lawyer
all right what do we uh what do we got
okay and the answer is
it's false
yeah they're all called simones but
stephen you won with three points to
gerald and dave's two i never lose
i can't lose
[Applause]
[Music]
put a lot of work into this yeah
about as much work as we have in the
connection with gingersnap better than
jurassic park dominion
now i know some of you have you're going
to be complaining why don't you just get
to the meat of it first and then some
you're going oh i wish that you didn't
do that you just did comedy so there's
no there's no way to please all you so
go to the lotus crowd.com tour go there
and uh you know what just
buy a ticket now yeah maybe just enjoy
the show yeah exactly where why don't we
do it all and you can just enjoy it
right yeah
let's just have a good time and
hopefully we'll see what happens in the
supreme court i'm having fun i'm having
fun yeah they say i always say that if
you're having fun that that means
everyone else the people watching having
fun that's not true no oh not true no
that's not true at all very not true i
saw a cannonball run
no yeah any movie really right like that
yeah
um
we put together a highlight reel of
hawaii's and this is actually i despise
this woman why
well you'll you'll see first off she's
barely literate okay
she's so she's an idiot
uh
she's a racist
um and she's also tried to actively get
this program removed from all of social
media
and by the way refused to take our calls
and refuse to have a conversation
with me so by the way senator hirono you
are welcome to come on the show
and i will not be uh kind i'll be polite
but i do not like you let's take a
stroll down hawaii's representative who
might be the worst in the country i
would request that my colleague senator
cruz not mistake mistake what i'm saying
and you know what all this men's
mansplaining please stop
but it is the basis on which you
determine that the oha elections were
unconstitutional well this is the
supreme
supreme court agreed though youtube
dragged its feet before taking any
action against conservative commentator
stephen crowder when youtube did finally
take action it took the half measure of
removing advertisements from crowder's
videos rather than removing him from the
platform entirely now look i understand
that i should be most upset with the
fact that she's trying to remove the
livelihood of myself and everyone in
here but advertisements
i thought that was more like a french
thing
that's just what people say to try to
sound smart but right sounds stupid
well you know she she she takes her
scheduled hearings very seriously that's
true
i'm sorry that's too rude yes
it's truey nasa truly here in hawaii
gosh i just can't believe judge is like
so this is this is what they have in
hawaii hawaii is a terrible place yes
it's an awful place and hirono is one of
the absolute worst if hirono had her way
you would have no speech you would have
no firearms the government would be in
charge of every aspect of your life and
that is not a hint of hyperbole this is
always what i say is like look you need
to actually imagine what democrats like
hirono like pelosi like aoc what it
would look like in this country if they
had power unchecked yeah okay
let's let's remove the checks and
balances that we have which they want to
remove by the way
just imagine someone like hirono
without even the spineless republicans
like mitch mcconnell
standing in the way
it would be boom you say something
removed
yeah it would be boom oh wait uh 10
round magazines are going on no wait
actually we met all firearms boom gone
just remember when hirono said that
youtube had said you violated none of
their rules yes so she said your
punishment for violating no rules for
breaking no rules was that you should
have your livelihood removed no she was
mad that only my livelihood was removed
she was saying i should be banned oh
well making the point that she she
wanted you to go further half measures
right so that's that's the punishment
for breaking no rules was you had money
taken out of your pocket yeah and she
thought that that was a half measure
right eat for not breaking rules for not
breaking hey hirono how's your stock
portfolio doing by the way well we're
talking about rules for me and not for
the huh
is it good
i like that
sounds like a professional wrestler and
she dresses like one right if you throw
that jacket on a man that is a that's
just diamond dallas page just hear the
undertaker gong
i bet she's like oh my god it's a raging
[ __ ]
it's hirono she's like i keep losing
time for her advertisement
how did i do this
she's getting a lot of sponsors
[Music]
lisa thank you live he's not afraid to
speak truth
to power
all right is ginger snap there is are we
going to check in with him or is he
going to let us i think he might have a
interview all right and uh uh tool man
can we hit the so i can see him up on
there now oh yeah yeah okay cause i
can't see him i was looking down at the
monitor all right let's check in time
for scotus watch again with gingersnap
[Music]
by the way he hates that nickname that's
why it'll stick all right
gingersnap did you find somebody
well we did find somebody but then right
before you called they just started a
turf protest at freedom plaza so
everyone's running to freedom plaza
hold on
i thought i thought you meant turf war
you mean a protest of t-e-r-f's
uh they're all gonna go yell at jk
rowling i think with what they were
saying or something like that
so they're gone um there's a couple guns
there's a couple gun activists over here
that are yelling we might try to talk to
them nobody really wants to talk to me
they think my mustache is too cool or
something i'm not really sure that must
be it what's happening
would you like to talk
you have it you look very patriotic
[Laughter]
go get
we are streaming live right now to
the whole country okay yes so what is
the get up
well i think it's important that women
we decide for our parish i don't think a
man have the pride of the churches to
decipher ourselves if we want to have an
evolution we're going to have an
abortion because it's important that
women have the right choice to decipher
their own body imagine if somebody is
great
or somebody a family member abused
a young girl and she get brain insects
you don't want that young girl to have
to carry with this pain and suffer it
through her life
if we allow abortions for all rape and
incest would she uh then uh consider
legislating other abortions
okay so so
if we ban abortions foreign
so like everybody that gets raped or
incest is a factor and we say yes you
can have an abortion
women no we ban all the rest of them
oh so it's not about abortion it is
about about this about those these two
points about women getting great about
incest and a women's choice so it's
three things very important she's
changing the count
to
carry a baby she doesn't want to carry
but she did she what about the baby
inside does it get to make a choice or
is it just not a person what's going on
with the baby it's very hard for women
to hear about men talking how do you
know i'm a man
you look like a man she's assuming my
gender she's a turf she's a turf
i don't know maybe today's different yes
i still think i can interpret the
constitution all right yes do you have a
fetal chart there
uh ginger snap
explain the thing on your face as a
landing strip
but what about my right you are not
telling me what is my right and i don't
have to ask a man
why they have to get in uh nine months a
baby when somebody's being raped when
somebody they keep going back to that
this is you're seeing it live and sorry
gingersnap it's gonna be distracting but
this is the straw man that they use this
is the red herring that they use it's
not about rapid incest she just she just
admitted that but they have to focus on
those issues otherwise no one will
support their cause yeah ask her is it
does she only do women only have to
follow laws made by women and men only
laws by men because that's the standard
we're setting also nine months i what
was your point there
everywhere
yes we're gonna get them out
if if they overturn if they overturn roe
tomorrow what are you going to do we're
going to keep fighting
we're going to go to the streets we have
the right or the free speech ask her
very plainly if they keep roe v wade
what she'll do people have to die
because they want to have an abortion
illegal okay so we're gonna keep
fighting
what if the court says okay we keep roe
v wade tomorrow then what do you do
well we
we're going to celebrate if they made
them even though that's even though
that's men deciding it
we're going to celebrate
we're going to the street so we're
guarding the streets either way yes
we're going to the streets baby but one
is to celebrate but ask her why she
would celebrate men making the decision
on abortion even if they keep roe v wade
but if you think about it
there's six men on the supreme court
right that's okay but if they'd be there
but what if they say row is good and we
keep row that's six men actually six men
made row seven men made it just they
made history again so it's okay for men
to make good laws
well if men say yes that's me they're
listening to me and to everybody in this
country and that's why women shouldn't
have the right to vote
[Laughter]
they are the people who want to pretend
they are pure and they're all decent
people you don't know what they do all
right it's time to say gracias and adios
see what she does thank you very much
gracias thank you for speaking gracias
gracias
thank you
i like your flag
there were some conversations yeah there
was
yeah
yeah great i'm glad that my fan looks
like a skeletor serial killer
okay well i have to i have to be upfront
but yeah so that's what we are um we'll
probably be back out here tomorrow
morning when they make the actual
decision no no no you're gonna go over
to the turf protests that sounds
absolutely lovely what are you not doing
okay well we'll go to the turf thing and
then we'll come back here tomorrow we're
going to be just
we're out here for the people okay well
thank you i appreciate that you're doing
it for the people uh uh fill us in on
the turf protest because that sounds
hilarious thank you gingersnap stay safe
uh that's been gingersnap
[Music]
here's the thing i feel bad because he
has the earpiece yeah in and so i don't
want to distract him and to man you can
take the color bars there off the screen
this is just so you guys know as i'm
doing this the only way i can see them
if it goes on screen but i'm just
looking at an indian going beep
i sincerely mean this i will give ken
500 bucks if he can get her into bed and
get her to keep the baby
500 bucks isn't enough
i don't know all right how much you want
to add we're not doing this chip in come
on i'm not doing it what do you got no
here's the thing this is this is the
issue you've gone through and by the way
the change my mind book is probably
going to be coming out this fall
because you just saw in real time what
do they do is they say rape or incest
now sometimes people get mad at me and
i'll get conservatives mad at me where i
say look okay let's say we make an
exception for rape and incest okay we
make an exception then are you willing
to and i don't even necessarily say ban
are you willing to legislate
other
abortions that are entirely
elective and they go no no then it's not
about rape and incest yeah so you
eliminate it off the it's not that i
support abortion in any capacity but the
point is take it off the table because
when forced to actually argue their
position and that lady is very clear she
even said nine months all the way up
until nine months including birth period
guess what that's that's the platform of
the dnc they lose support that's why
when you look at an arbitrary polling
that says hey do you support a woman's
right to choose oh yeah i think so and
then you say hey do you support aborting
an uh an eight-month-old they go no of
course not ah well see those are two
which one is closer to the reality of
the policy and then we also see her
saying men should not have a men should
not have a say what happens if roe v
wade is and i i say they rule to keep
roe v wade but basically you're talking
about ruling it as a precedent that
it'll stay
effectively the law of the land she goes
then it's good then we'll celebrate okay
so it's not about men
having an opinion it's not about men
signing
laws hey did you vote did you vote for
hillary clinton in the primaries versus
barack obama
let's p do you only vote for women
unless you exclusively and only vote for
women you cannot say that men
can have no position on legislation
because you voted them in so she said
well well then we'll celebrate it and
that's why we have a problem with and
i'm mostly joking but feminists voting
the root cause of almost all of our
issues here that we are dealing with in
north america today is
not women but feminism and by the way
sometimes that permeates even good
non-feminist
individuals who don't even necessarily
realize it that is a double standard let
me ask you this okay well men can't have
a position on
abortion if i don't like it okay got it
but they can keep it and then i'll
support it okay got it you have no say
in what i do with my body okay got it
but if i keep it you have to pay alimony
no matter what do i get a choice
think of the lack of consistency there
and it's the same thing with a marital
contract the abortion issue acts as
though men play no role in creating or
rearing a child yeah and then we wonder
why fatherhood is devalued in this
society we wonder why we have a problem
this entire conversation
is centered around the idea that the
baby may or may not be a nuisance to the
woman even in the laws
do we ever talk about the father having
a choice that's oppressive hands off my
uterus hold on a second
that's not your dna that's not my that
is a new genetic code that by the way
came from my sperm and your egg
yeah oh i've been carrying it i've been
carrying it for nine months
i don't know the l i don't know how long
that's been in my balls
a couple of days maybe probably three
days but she's also making she's making
a false point here she's saying that
women across the country want this okay
well what about the giant swath millions
and millions and millions and millions
of women who don't who want pro-life
policies you're just assuming that every
single woman out there supports your
cause and that's not true
right
so you're saying that well again it
assumes that women are a monolith it
really is a problem true at all with
it's hey
free sex great got it
no cat calling what
then how do you know that i want free
sex hey i have the ability to use sex as
empowerment okay here are my tits got it
don't look
oh look and this is a double with a
double standard men aren't sexualized in
the workplace look just to be clear uh
showing your breath that's not true
that's not true well that's mostly
gerald but
showing your breast is not a fashion
statement
naked men
showing your breast is not a fashion
statement let's use an exact example
there's a double standard okay you ever
see the sports illustrated covers these
magazines where they're painted on the
painted suits
when was the last time i came out here
with my scrotum and uh and gland's penis
painted like a bumblebee and said it's
paint
it was tuesday and then if you look at
it i say hey hey what are you doing eyes
up here eyes up here well you're showing
me your balls well so what i'm showing
my balls for me not for you
it inspires confidence it's a bumblebee
not my balls i don't know when was the
last time you were tackled by a police
officer
beaten without mercy and no one cared
right
hey by the way uh what is it 97
it's either 94 or 97 percent of
workplace workplace deaths are men
if you walked into a bank and pulled out
a gun it would get a better reaction
than if you pulled out your penis yes
that's true absolutely true the only
place where i would get uh you know
praise would be um on a disney movie lot
that's true well then they'd be like
this is great here's your childhood oh
you must be the child actor tutor let's
write this way to his trailer uh you're
doing story time correct yes dressed
like a bumblebee yeah it's a pop out yes
um hey by the way uh control room can we
get the info on exactly what's happening
here with the supreme court uh the new
york uh concealed carry law so let's get
uh the some some quotes officially what
they said and if we have a clip for
later on because this is happening live
we'll check back in with gingersnap
and the turf protest i would assume
there's
[Music]
is he back in no no but i i i just
screwed up was that your coconut titty
that hit the it pretty much was he's got
amazing at this point
yeah so basically they were saying that
you do have the right i just saw one of
the the headlines you do have the right
to carry a gun outside of the home and
that's part of this uh ruling so we'll
get a little bit more deep well the
ruling better include in new york that
you're also allowed a firearm in the
home well because
that's the starting point in manhattan
yeah i think they were saying there's a
lot of them just will bring them into
your house anyway yeah no it's so
difficult to i don't know what the law
is in manhattan as far as actually even
owning a handgun in your own house or
apartment honestly i don't know either
it's it's very very strict there it's
very strict there was an episode of
billions that talked about getting
somebody a permit that was the whole
plot for the entire episode to carry you
need a sheriff i believe you need a
sheriff to actually carry manhattan but
i don't know what the law is now because
they've sort of had to chip away at it
and they've reached they've then added
to it it just becomes this frankenstein
monster of gun laws
and uh you mean a sheriff you have to
have a sheriff at least i know in los
angeles for a period of time i think
ouch for you or yeah you actually have
the sheriff say you have the right to
own really you have a legitimate need
right you have to show and uh i i didn't
get mine when i lived in manhattan
because it said legitimate need and i
just uh wrote
am american
see second amendment yeah
for further details are you trying to
get cute you're trying to get cutesy hey
we're gonna take you downtown on a paddy
wagon see part of the militia he named
several races yes
all right speaking of useless uh
absolutely useless laws and or people
aoc there's a flashback uh because she
just doubled down on it
and here's my question to you i haven't
done a question of the day yet i guess
is uh how tone deaf can someone get who
is the most tone deaf person
in our hollowed halls of
government hollowed out hallowed however
you want to say
30 i'm 32
afc
good lord the coconut breasts are going
to your brain here to a man today
all right so she just doubled down on it
to complain on instagram about her uh
middle-class income yes
which you know 173 000 74 thousand
dollars i believe yeah
i didn't adjust for stupidity and uh
here is her back uh in december
complaining about it 30 i'm 32 years old
now
i have
over 17 000 dollars in student loans oh
you poor thing to pay it off and i
didn't go to graduate school we can tell
because
i knew
because you couldn't read the scantron
with your google eyes drown me in debt
that i would never be able by buying a
tesla wait never be able to pay it
seriously this is
unacceptable
hold on a second she has 17 000 in debt
yeah seventy thousand dollars of student
loan debt she makes 174 thousand dollars
a year she'd never be able to pay back
well she's no she said so we don't try
to buy a used car right yeah no kidding
no half of a used car what are you
talking about
it's not it's really not all that much
no it's not jesus you maybe should have
pulled a bigger number wait yeah but you
see how much houses cost right yeah
wait til you see how a garbage disposal
works
oh boy i hope your furnace doesn't go
out right so stupid she's like hey i
couldn't afford to go out and get enough
let's say that a master's is going to
cost you 50 000 kind of for a middle of
the road degree but you're going to make
an extra 75 000 over the course of three
or four or five years like you couldn't
do the math on that and go oh it's not
never paid off it's like paid off in
five years it is stupid though you
shouldn't get a masters like i don't
think you should go to college anymore
i'm just saying that was a really poor
argument hey here's actually question
before i get to some of the math this is
this is genuine uh with twins now i
actually am leaning towards i prefer
that they don't go to university
potentially yeah i prefer that they
either go to a trade school or start a
business and i'm hoping that by that
point they can just do everything online
so i was gonna say the archaic system of
degrees yeah yeah i have a fund for a
trade school in college but i i'm i
really want him to consider a trade
school yeah for my son i have since
before he was born
yeah i mean it's just it's a much
quicker path yeah it's a much more
lucrative path and it also lends itself
to you know you can then create a
business well and i look at my own path
where it's like look i didn't care about
school i liked making jokes you can do
what you want with your life you just
have to honestly follow the path you
want to follow and you just here's the
thing you can do it and you can follow
the path even if it's a typical path if
you are willing to work your ass off yes
you just have to be willing to fail too
yeah deal with rejection and move
forward like you can't just think well
17 grand i don't know what i'll do i
guess that's that
i mean bankruptcy here i come i can't
afford no chevy cavalier i mean for
crying out loud 174 000 and like and she
thinks i mean do you have any idea that
men kill themselves for less as a life
insurance policy if i put away slightly
less than 10 of my income just for one
year i could be debt free how about this
how about if i don't drive a tesla she
drives a tesla
poorly manhattan well yeah in parks and
handicap space yes yeah i'm just saying
there's 17 000 laying around somewhere
babe yeah yeah the car is 70 000.
somewhere in there you can pay this off
what an
ass of it he just was she never
considered she's irresponsible with the
money yeah
again what does this go back to the
problem with what what what what what
what feminism in this country the
problem with feminist ideals not
femininity let's be really clear i think
we really need to separate feminism
versus femininity because feminism is
not feminine it's the problem of i i
can't be held responsible
what i can you believe that i have this
debt every single guy is going like um
yeah yeah 17 is not that much do you
have any idea
what men do
as far as the debt that they take on i
would i would love that you can't find
the stat i would love to know how many
women had their thumbs broken by the mob
well
you know ever ever
ever yeah they can pay for stuff with
stuff we don't have right she's like i
just you know i did you have any idea
what citibank will do to me if i don't
stow away nine percent of my once a year
salary
they're gonna call me and do nothing
when i understand if somebody's
listening going hey seventeen thousand
dollars is a lot of money to me i
understand that it is a lot of money but
it she took out a 17 000 loan to invest
in a salary that gets her
174 000 a year do you see why it's
stupid yes and by the way i understand
that in washington dc that doesn't go a
long way like in new york city that
technically that maybe is middle class i
get it but guess what
you're all for public transit why don't
you live an hour out of dc and take the
train there you go instead you have to
live does she live in arlington i
believe i believe she lives in virginia
she lives i believe she lives in
arlington virginia uh in a very
expensive apartment
within likely close to walking distance
certainly public transit distance to her
place of
work
and she drives a tesla
come on babe at a certain point i i
picture a man and i remove all reason
and accountability
aoc so
let's go through she claims that her uh
her uh
six digit salary here makes her middle
working class icon that's twice the
median household income in the united
states
very not so much average not individual
median
right household median household that
means two yeah
potentially it takes two papers so if
you make them as much as four people yes
poor girl effectively
by the way i don't know how much it
takes to get the eye fixed but consider
it yeah i don't know if there's a lasik
for
googly braces go ahead and add 3 000 to
the debt yeah yeah that's right yeah
that way you can change your driver's
license which is i type googly
[Laughter]
and now she just whined about it loan
forgiveness again on an instagram post
oh my gosh and by the way the plsf this
is the abbreviation is about uh service
loan uh public service loan forgiveness
is what she's talking about let's also
go through here's one thing to 174 000
uh working for the government is not
just 174 000
right they have travel covered by the
taxpayers they have free airport parking
they have an on-site gym the kind of
insurance they have for health insurance
is unbelievable they have special
license plates allowing them privileges
they have a much better 401k than you
have and they have this representational
allowance that could be anywhere from
1.2 to three point three million all
references are available at
lightworkcrowder.com the point is this
is not just a hundred seventy four
thousand dollars a year for example
business owners are vilified if they say
you're part of the top one percent
you're making 250 000 a year let's say a
business owner making an individual
income of 250 000 a year as opposed to
suckling at the government teat that
gets whittled down to far less than aoc
salary if you just look at the health
insurance the retirement he has to save
for himself the actual taxes that he
pays so there is a very skewed scale
that's why a lot of people want to go
into it's not public service here's the
problem i think that public servants
should be given enough to live and no
more
no more i think there should be no
financial incentive to go into public
office none whatsoever the only
president who we really know with him
that was was donald trump we know that
he was taking a pay cut when he became
president
now you can argue that maybe some people
do it for power people do it for ego
sure but let's remove that
corrupter of the soul
right money there should be no financial
incentive i am a servant really not so
much by the way you know what she said
in that instagram post she said
that the reason that there's corruption
in government is because you pay people
so little and it forces them to have to
make ends meet somehow i'm not kidding
she uses the insider trading thing and
saying this is the unintended
consequence by not paying us enough
money people will go out and make ends
meet by doing insider trading that's why
you were fellating adam schiff
absolutely what what
no i meant her allegedly allegedly
allegedly allegedly yeah that's it's
true you know when you remove all
options then eric swallow has to bang
his ninth chinese spy that's true he's
going to say
that he's a traitor and she is yeah
that's her argument
like oh
again again it's f it's just like uh
with uh we let's compare it directly to
amber heard yes i took a poop in his bed
but you made me do it yes i hit johnny
depp but you made me do it yes i i'm
financially corrupt but you made me do
it you don't pay me enough is there ever
any accountability we just picked
a random woman a random woman there in
dc right now and she has the exact same
mindset as aoc is there ever anything
that is aoc's fault
with feminists is there ever genuine
question
what is your fault hey what is your
responsibility woman when it comes to a
baby is it only what responsibility
there
sex protection i'm allergic to latex
use lamb skin
i don't want to i've been using that one
for years yeah but it doesn't really
work if you just use rabbit skin with a
zip tie that's true
or is it not a diy
[Laughter]
just
aoc ah ah student loans
is that your is it your responsibility
the money and the the reason that
everyone here in dc is corrupt is that
at all your fault
can you do something didn't you go there
into office to try and fix it well my
only fix is you pay me more
well my only fix is you pay for my
abortion yeah well my only fix is you
absolve my student debt is there ever
any accountability and you wonder why
some 40 something percent of young men
don't want to get married right did you
seek out the institution so that you
could go to a university apply there to
several other institutions so that you
could possibly get in and then sign a
document that said here's how you pay
for it and pray to god that you got
approved right and now you're
complaining that you got approved got to
the university that you wanted to go to
and now you have a little bit of debt
which you knew you would have in the
first place yeah it's kind of like a
responsibility it's like colin
kaepernick saying that the nfl is
slavery and then trying really hard to
get into us
i need tryouts for slavery give me then
casting hundreds of people and picking
the ones that looked most like slaves
yes exactly even though i'm still not
convinced he himself is a black guy no
why oh well he's got no well if you look
at his high school pictures he's not
we all remember that 12 years a slave
when he runs back
yeah but
he's blacker than sean it's the
what is the tax bracket of somebody like
aoc too is it nothing or does she i
don't know what the marginal tax rate is
i bet for her for somebody like her
well it depends if you also again they
have a they have an allowance so it's
like it's all offset a 1.2 million
dollar allowance yeah i mean think about
this we were sitting here we were going
like and by the way do consider do we
have a promo code token on for cultural
appropriation month
promo code uh we do i believe it's a
culture it is entering the promo code
culture lottery with crowder.com mug
club and uh we'll be taking a lot of
your chest today's gonna go long just
because we're waiting to see what
happens with the supreme court so this
is kind of a there you go you know we're
we're uh we have plenty of uh we have
plenty of stories to get to but i'm
waiting to see what gingersnap has there
at the the turf protest but we were
scraping together pennies going like all
right can we send out how many cameramen
can we send out okay one the answer is
one we can send out gingersnap sorry you
don't get security and uh
meanwhile she can have a two point
something million dollar allowance
what what what for
what for just just drive your tesla into
work and shut up yeah also why does
somebody who's making decisions for this
country have a seventeen thousand dollar
education well that's just her debt left
i'm not even convinced that that's a
student she's not that old no yeah
bartender yeah my look i went it's a
student loan i went to i went to
university of amex
i uh pretty sure that's what i paid for
community college and i paid cash from
selling weed
allegedly allegedly other than the
convictions the other ones are alleged
yeah allegedly well i i learned the
stuff about film and i was like i don't
want to learn the other stuff and i left
yeah is that why you went to film school
yeah i just learned about film yeah
that's what i did too yeah i went to
film school and then i didn't want to
take the classes because i didn't want
to know about the stuff i did i was an a
student my first year and then i have
nightmares about the transcripts my
second year because i was doing stand-up
and i remember i actually had the
realization where my spanish teacher
who and i deserved to fail spanish i
just wrote in f i thought it'd be really
easy if i just wrote in french because i
speak french and then add an o
turns out
quite a bit more to it than that
and she said i don't know what you're
thinking what do you think you're trying
to be the class clown you think you're
going to be in the just for laughs or
something and i'd gotten the call the
week before that i made it so i was like
why am i here
what am i doing this is such a waste of
my time yes i'll be in just for last bye
yeah bio which wasn't even that big of a
deal it was just a local you know it's
just that's what we knew in montreal
anyways okay let's get to ezra miller
the pedophile
oh jeez
he's on the run he's on the lam movie
star he's on the lam like like a trojan
he's that he had sex with a lamb
he's on the old lamb skin the old lamb
skin jimmy hat
never understood that expression he's on
the lamb did someone ride a lamb away
from the authorities at some point that
would be very impractical someone can
explain it to me and i'll sound really
stupid like actually it just comes from
the latin term it was like something
something something romance languages
and what have you it's off the lam
so uh ezra miller you may not uh know
this uh he's the flash
aptly named what a coincidence
he also plays a troubled person in the
outdoor series he's missing after two
families accused him of of grooming one
child and harassing another and actually
on june 18th the judge granted a
protective order for the second victim a
western massachusetts mother has been
granted a protection order by gracefield
district court on behalf of herself they
didn't hit the shift
a court order issued on wednesday
doesn't contain specific allegations but
did say it was issued with advanced
notice due to quote substantial
likelihood of immediate danger of
harassment
this mother spoke with nbc news under
the condition of anonymity saying that
she and her child first met miller in
february she soon grew suspicious of
miller as they continued to offer her
child gifts even after rejecting earlier
officers
miller has been no stranger to
controversy in recent months after a
series of arrests in hawaii and a
similar protection order filed earlier
this month in north dakota see that's
how it ties in pacific islands so the
photographs there are texts there are
eyewitness accounts to corroborate the
story in other words this wasn't just a
he said
he said story um with ezra miller uh
there was a lot of evidence right this
guy is at the very least done some
inappropriate stuff if not outright
sexual assault yeah so february let me
give you the timeline here a little bit
uh february 2nd ezra miller the flash by
the way and they that you know big tech
has started cracking down the term
groomer is actually i'm quite positive
is a term that gets throttled really
yeah because they've tried to say that's
that's a conspiracy term where they're
trying to say that liberals are a cabal
of pedophiles no no not all
just a lot so february 2nd miller
allegedly began harassing a mother and
her 12-year-old son
continued for months march 29 it was
reported that miller was arrested in
hawaii for disorderly conduct harassment
then on april 19th he was arrested
charged with second degree assault
and then june 7th this guy just cannot
stay out of
being an [ __ ] wow
june 7th the parents of dakota ironize
that's that's always their term like oh
yeah dakota iron dakota ironized dakota
iron [ __ ] this could be on the
parents on this one one who bullshits
bear dakota ironized did they even use
iron the native americans before he came
in pretty sure they used bones for their
actual like bones for their uh for their
arrows can someone fact check that i
don't think they used iron they didn't
lint they used them for the tomahawks
i don't think they did yeah they used
bone yeah that's right they did yeah
they used bone for their tomahawks i
don't think they used iron and if they
did they didn't know that it was iron
they certainly didn't call it iron they
weren't smelting
so june 7th the parents of
ironize filed uh for protective order
against miller alleging he drugged and
groomed um this girl and she was 12.
miller has since so he's an equal
opportunity molester boys and girls wow
what a good guy come one come all to
ezra miller he's since disappeared with
takata and posted memes
mocking the inability of authorities to
locate him uh and you'll get a kick out
of this by the way so at the beginning
of that we talked about the february
12th incidents they had invited ezra
over for a board game because he knew
somebody that they knew right so they
were at a neighbor's house ezra miller
one of ezra's friends was friends with
this couple they went to a board game
the couple of the child yeah and so the
child was there the mom was there and
the mom dresses goth which should have
been one of the tip-offs here yeah but
they were playing parcheesi and she
dresses goth as all good uh cheyenne and
tribesmen do well dress gotham
that'll be relevant just a second one
who purchases that hot topic that's this
isn't the uh indian part no it's not the
american oh it's the other one the other
parents yeah february 12. so ezra is
playing parcheesi and snaps and says
something about it being cultural
appropriation for one of the the
questions or topics that they're
covering and starts yelling at somebody
and then the goth lady asks a question
and he starts berating her for dressing
goth and and starting to make comments
like to the child your outfit looks so
fantastic i love your fashion this is
great like tell me a little bit more
about your shoes and like being very
very awkward was the dad there the dad
was there the dad said something ezra
miller opens up his jacket has a flak
jacket on and a firearm and says making
comments like that will end up in a very
serious situation
this person is absolutely crazy yeah
this is a very dangerous personally
crazy you don't invite this person over
to play board games no you don't okay
you don't invite him over uh period
unless it's uh you know
you know well then this person's the the
child said that they liked horses to
kill him what a weird evening two months
later ezra miller shows up at their
house dressed as a cowboy
hmm well it's better than the flash i
guess and here's the thing there are so
many red flags there but we can't say it
right hey hey i'm uh i'm uh i'm blatant
i'm i'm bisexual okay okay that's fine
there's that's completely okay and also
by the way uh i hang around with kids uh
okay all right we understand it and by
the way uh that's cultural appropriation
like uh okay i guess i like dressing
like a cowboy and doing hyper sexualize
well you know what your your choice is
just as legitimate as mine and then we
act like we're surprised yeah would any
of us be surprised if a good portion of
those people over there at the uh scotus
right now or this turf protest
are sexual deviants
no
they are i guarantee it yeah cry it out
loud it's what happens when you just let
everybody do anything that they want
because they're you're okay with them
being sex that's the whole thing is
there's sexually weird and you're like
great right it's fantastic yeah oh he
showed us a gun how's that yeah well
i would say something if he weren't gay
with my son well i can't say something
about him because it's they right that's
right he's they the article said it
several times and i'm like wow hey at
what point do you have permission to
just be a dick to the person who wants
neutral pronouns right you know what if
i'm if i'm a journalist i go uh they
because that's a you know what not only
does the grammar bother me as a
journalist but raped a kid i'm going to
write he
think if we're still catering to a child
rapist who wants to be they
oh the creepy pedos here dressed up like
a cowboy good i said i liked horses
probably shouldn't have said that we'll
uh we'll go with yahtzee this time
because we know how offended you were
parcheesi of course are bad
do you like to play hungry hungry gay
men yes have you ever seen the game
called wahoo right up your alley
let's play clue because we don't have
one let's play marbles oh you want to
stuff as many in my mouth and see how
long it takes before i can't describe oh
yeah i said i don't know where to plant
is the game of life yours won't be long
let's play telephone i'm calling the
cops they don't care well people say i'm
threatening i if i'm a dad
and we're talking about the situation
i'm a dad and he's sexually
commenting on my child and i've said hey
don't do that and then he shows that
he's willing yeah he's willing to go to
violence just to continue sexually
accosting my son yeah if that man comes
back to my house
he gets shot there's a problem yeah i'm
not just i'm not saying you go out
because you don't like his shitty show
what i'm saying is hey don't say sexual
stuff to my son and he shows me a gun in
my house i would have been like huh oh
i'm sorry i'm really sorry i'll be uh uh
uh i'll be right back bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang click bang bang bang
reload click bang bang bang bang bang
bang bang then you get the one oh yeah
steak and the garlic just to be safe
yes silver
well you pee on the ashes yes yeah i'm
just saying and by the way we spoke just
so you know we spoke with hawaiian
police yesterday evening so um according
to their dispatch
there are no charges pending in hawaii
right now but there is an apb out for
him um regarding a theft
in april oh yeah and i think uh
breaking news
[Music]
i'll take care of this
it always
looks pretty relaxed yeah it does seem
like it
all right all right well that seems like
uh that's pretty good yeah yeah that
seems uh like he's having a good time i
wasn't kidding you know what you're
gonna wait
i'll take care of it okay and i will
take care of it okay okay we're in the
middle of a show yeah oh geez okay
i'll be back i guess he's really
i guess he's really gonna go into well i
think he gets inspired you know he
doesn't have a high tolerance for um for
for really any of this
stuff oh my gosh bring up bring up cnn
bring it up
come on look at this is cnn breaking
news
ha
[ __ ]
oh at least there's a happy ending all
you needed was troy palamalu there we go
i don't know how to say that name uh
dave
thanks for
for being back no trouble
what are you doing huh
just refreshing myself with a coke zero
[Music]
you gonna check the whole thing
[Music]
yum you've just guaranteed yourself
tooth decay there's a lot of money in
this zero calorie beverage oh zero
mm-hmm it's refreshing
pedophile no i love how this program is
more of a liability when we actually
plug sponsors who don't want to be
associated with yeah
they're going to call us and be like
never promote us again like never
promote coke we're like all right and
then next time we just have a pepsi can
up but then we pull off the label that's
so cool
gotcha and rc cola is like guys we'd
love a we'd love some spots doc i also
drank a gallon of head and shoulders
before i did that ah yes yeah which by
the way reminds me you might want to go
to a doctor dave yeah it would explain
that
yeah why you were in the bathroom for 30
minutes before the show that's true i
think it was the cheesecake factory i
ordered three slices last night stayed
up crying i think it's mostly the head
and shoulders
and you wash it down with some nice
nizerole
now um let's uh let me know when uh
gingersnap if he's over there at the
turf protest uh and until then uh let's
continue here the state department
just released a video or didn't just
release a video but
recent enough that i'm mad about it yeah
well you should be
do you do you want to go to him real
fast
yeah oh okay all right
let's hit the stinger it's time to do
ginger snap scotus watch
[Music]
all right so he is down so gingersnap
can you uh can you hear me
is he being chased by the police
he's either being chased by the police
or is it a fisher price exhibit okay we
got him all right gingersnap thank you
for being here uh with us sir now i am
willing to bet before you say a word
that is an attractive lady who looks
like she has herself together
conservative
well i don't know her political
affiliation but i know where she stands
on the females
[Applause]
okay all right well let's get to it so
to kind of set up we came over from the
supreme court because the people got
done protesting there ran over here and
there when you look over there real
quick
they're doing uh
basically keep biological males out of
female sports
so they're asking so they are
anti-biological males in female sports
yes this this group over here is
anti-biological males of course you can
probably guess what this group over here
is
uh
i can guess and i don't think the term
is one that uh we're allowed to say on
youtube uh [ __ ] so ones that don't
look like they
play sports yeah exactly yeah the ones
who i mean maybe maybe a little bit of
shuffleboard okay so tell us who we're
talking with here and what our
involvement is yes
so who are you
you wanted to do this [ __ ] ginger snap
this is your idea
he's next to a pretty girl and he loses
it
i don't know where you're doing this
with an earbud by the way
can't hear we can't hear her i think
you're covering the mic or the earbud
isn't aimed at her
no we could not hear anything there lane
you got your thumb on the mic ginger
snap you have your thumb on the mic i
think you need to hold i think you need
to hold the earbud aiming at her yeah
there you go let's see if that works
like that go ahead
let's hear
her in here no i think the earbud is
broken you might just be better off
putting them in your ears ask her if
it's okay if you get your face really
close to hers put them both in your ears
because the mic is auto detecting and
put them both in your ears put both
earbuds in your ears no both in your
ears
all right put them both in your ears and
just lean in
are we good let me hear her now
yeah
okay my name is riley gaines i just
recently graduated from the university
of kentucky where i was on the swim team
um and leah thomas died this past march
at our instant play championship tied in
the 200-yard three cell
um and when we tied dave's chevrolet
handed the trophy to thomas because they
only had one and told me
that leah needed to hold the trophy
hold on a second she tied leah thomas
she tied leah thomas
so it's a tie
yeah we um went to the exact same time
which is pretty rare in swimming um down
to the 100th so they obviously only had
one fifth place trophy
but they told me i could pose with the
sixth place
[Music]
[Laughter]
rather than me and he said well we're
just basing it on chronological order
at this point i'm like okay well what
are we being chronological about because
maybe i'm missing something but we try
um and he just looked at me and said
and
um
that's when i kind of realized that not
only were we forced to compete against
men but we were put on the back
maybe maybe leah thomas's penis crossed
first can you imagine being someone who
would prefer a photo of leah thomas than
her
potentially men's health
so has the ncaa said anything to you
since then
um for anyone there's been tons of
letters tons of different organizations
reaching out um
let me ask her something would she be
willing to go with you over to those
protesters to tell her story and see
what their reaction is because i don't
you know for them to actually meet
someone who has been directly affected
by a man and woman sports maybe they
might have some empathy do you want to
ask her and see if she'd be willing to
go over with you
yeah i'll ask her um
so he's just wondering if you have ever
talked to her would talk to one of them
and explain your story to them
i mean i would obviously they're they're
trying to get the right going because
they don't want people to hear
the almost common sense that's being
spewed over here that's true so i would
be very willing to it it seems more so
that they are the unwilling ones to have
a conversation about it right i would
get that jacked guy behind her though to
go over there yes it's a monster yeah
because seriously on the left of the
screen yeah yeah that dude was right
there yeah seriously dude looks like the
hulk
okay well you know what lane let's keep
you on the line and see if if you and
this lovely lady um just uh if if you go
over and just let us know when you talk
with those people what i would just like
is for her to tell her story and see
what these women say because you know
they've always said men shouldn't have
an opinion on this and so we just went
from that at the abortion issue to right
now i would love to hear them discuss
with a woman who had her trophy
effectively taken by biological email so
let me know when you get over there uh
good or bad what happens
okay yeah i'll shoot a line
and we'll make sure that you get her
phone number for you know to get her to
sign a release uh not because you're
single
yeah yeah excellent all right thank you
thank you gingersnap we'll check back in
all right what a great kind
yeah
[Music]
but they chose a man over a woman in a
tie in women's sports yeah for photo
purposes for photo purposes yeah what a
beautiful that'd be like taking down the
picture of fairy faucet on your ceiling
to put up emo phillips
[Laughter]
what say you fuzzy britches
you take that down that's how skewed oh
it's just this oh oh you think she's
prettier than leah thomas because of
society yes i think she's prettier than
leah thomas because of society biology
yeah
yeah or just the fact that that's what
men are attracted to oh you mean pretty
feminine nice or the fact that she's
obviously an excellent athlete and
articulate yeah here's the thing there's
people we were just talking about this
they would try and paint conservative
christians and say they were trying to
censor content before now no no look a
parental advisory warning is not
censoring content a rating system for
age propriety so that parents can do
their job you can still change the
channel if you don't like it yeah it's
just that parents need to be informed as
to these decisions so when you look at
what the christian right was asking for
it'd be very similar to food labels in
other words a food label can't say this
is 40 grams of sugar when it's actually
80 grams of sugar christian
conservatives were just saying it needs
to say 80 grams of sugar because we're
parents and maybe my kid's a diabetic
that's the issue that happened there now
they're just trying to literally drown
out voices with whom they disagree on
the same uh by that same uh same token
you know it used to be people on the
left who were everything was [ __ ] and
[ __ ] right the objective it wasn't
christian conservatives who objectified
women but now we're accused of objectif
by saying she's very pretty she's a very
pretty woman and i guaran you know who
else is saying that every single
straight male and objective female
watching right now comment below comment
below is that and i don't mean in any
type of an inappropriate way is that not
a more attractive
woman than leah thomas and to women out
there objectively do you think it's do
you think that it's uh it's demeaning do
you think it's objectification for men
to say oh good-looking articulate woman
that's someone who i'd like as an
ambassador not the chick with a dick
well and let's just put it this way if
your only argument is coming with a
cowbell you're full of [ __ ]
yeah they're just trying to disturb
people yeah it's not pretty good
it's enough already
that's just i mean for crying out just
think of how what would we say would we
say
a couple hundred hours total of change
my mind that have gone up yeah where
we've gone up but we listen and we talk
think of the most heated it's ever
gotten think of the most asshole-ish
that we've ever been
and compared to just clank clank clank
clank clank clank is that a woman who
actually worked hard to get into a swim
no no no she can't talk clink clink
clink clink clink
no and the the people that have debated
you i mean for the most part aren't the
ones that show up with a boom box and
stuff like that they've sat there and
talked to you they're not debates or
conversations yeah yeah i shouldn't say
debates yeah the people that sit there
and talk to you aren't the ones that are
standing there ten feet away afraid to
actually talk to you i know you know
blaring a boom box or whatever it is
they do this is ridiculous i mean
this girl is 100 percent
right can we have someone google her uh
in the control room there and see
because she said she tightly at thomas
i'm not mistaken university of
kentucky's she said two in the 200 or
the 100 i think she's the 200. she said
it was down to a 100th of a second so it
could be in the 200 yeah 200 and the
200. yep so let's find out who she is so
he just lia thomas just won by a glance
penis
oh and the fact that she's taller well
maybe maybe she he's taller yeah not
necessarily taller but bigger hands that
touch yeah
flippers i guess
the the foreskin
something happened
but this is the whole point you know
nobody wants to have a conversation they
just want to go and yell and bang things
and make some noise and say our voices
no your voices weren't heard you were
annoying that was it these are the same
people by the way who just said no men
should have opinions on abortion which
by the way in other words
no men should have an opinion on saving
the life of a seven month girl seven
month old girl in the womb because
that's sexist
and those same people now went to
protest the women saying biological men
shouldn't be taking over actual female
spaces
this is you just saw it in real time yes
no vagina no opinion
how about no vagina no women's sports
fascist oh come on third reich much
it makes no sense i know it honestly
makes no sense that you yeah men should
never talk about abortion but we do feel
that any man should be able to uh fight
a woman in a boxing ring yes yes as long
as you believe that any man should be
able to
just watch the rabbit punches cl i want
good clean breaks uh bob and tina yeah
what were you saying nobody no nothing
below the belt for
her yes because of her her pains
you can punch her in the vagina all
right toca no one's trying to come in
sorry yeah i'm just that was riley
gaines i got the picture right here
oh sorry i'm missing oh oh yeah why
would you do that to us
oh my god look at the poor fourth thing
remember
remember how i get uh can you just put
that back up real quick remember how i
guessed he was she was taller
oh that could also be the podium because
even though they placed at the exact
same time they put leah thomas up higher
oh right right yeah for the photography
is probably taller no i think she i
think she no i'm not gonna do this
[ __ ] i think he's on an elevated
platform can we pan out yeah can we sit
further is there a full body shot yeah
no well no they wouldn't
only allow you know from the waist up
for leah thomas yeah like back when they
did the tom jones variety hour because
the balls are hanging out of them
no no they have a new bathing suit with
cupped areas oh right yeah she's wearing
a
jacques
that's how hirono pronounces it i missed
a a a jack
strap
this is stupid
it's stupid here's the thing it's evil
disguise is stupid look
the devil's never gonna show up in a
creaky coffin in a haunted house the
devil shows up in a way that seems
appealing the devil shows up in a way
that subverts what you think is normal
the devil shows up and says that evil
right something about the bible saying
they will call evil good and good evil
and good evil
we just saw that in real time they will
call good evil
the
valuing of human life and by the way
what i'm saying this is something we're
all on board with they call
they call good evil in a sense if we say
how about you don't have an abortion
at seven months
that's policy just to be clear yeah they
will call that good evil and they will
call the evil a man beating a woman
and i i don't not just figuratively
physically they call that good yeah well
they call killing children
at nine months good good good and we
don't say that because we're like
exaggerating no if you elect to have an
abortion and your child is at nine
months and the child comes out and is
born alive
we have video evidence of the doctor
saying we'll keep that child comfortable
and we'll we'll will yeah essentially
let them die that was the whole point to
this i've certainly have different we've
certainly discussed that i'm more
liberal on it than you nine months is
not right abortion yeah most there's no
way
like an abortion yeah also if you hang
the picture of you beating her in your
house and show that to people
it's just
i don't understand but this is uh
this is my crowning achievement this is
when i won the female swim competition
well i tied but they gave it to me
because of my dick yes it's a handicap
you know what they call evil you know
what they call evil
me liking my women to have uh
a real vagina and or tits they say
that's evil what you're gonna
discriminate you know what i think is
evil
a man who's lived as a man his entire
life beating up women in the cage or in
boxing even swimming even non-contact
sports
i think that's evil you think it's evil
that i like a woman to have been born
a female
guys there there is no middle ground
here on this there really isn't a middle
ground when people try and say oh
there's a middle ground because i think
the transgender individuals should be
allowed to live of course that's not a
middle ground no one who's on the right
is saying that you should go and beat up
transgender individuals who just happen
to identify as something that they think
they are in their life that's not a
middle ground because none of us are
advocating against that that's not a
middle ground if you believe that and
you also believe that they shouldn't
compete in women's sports or that
biology is a real thing you are now a
conservative who are you going to put
labels on it man because the dnc the
democratic platform
puts a policy statement out on it the
former vice president joe biden of the
united states said the most important
thing you can do
with your young child
is affirm their gender meaning affirm
whatever it is that they identify to be
i don't know i think the most important
thing you could do is feed clothe them
teach them right from wrong
educate maybe be grateful that you live
in a country that's so amazing that you
can just make [ __ ] up
it just used to be that we were like go
make it up and do it on your own time
yeah never before my language but it's
just unbelievable there's so i hate i
really don't like the fact that you can
look at that and go well that just means
you're anti-trans you're hateful no it
doesn't the fact that a man tied with a
woman in a sport and you automatically
go for the man who's dressed as the
woman is ridiculous
sorry
i was right no she's she's not an
elevated poet no she's not i don't think
by the way do they put a stripper pole
behind the girl she's not this guy
they're all the same thing they're on
the same thing
they're in the same podium yep that she
she's still tied with her can you bring
it up again even though she's a foot
taller than her
well you're not considering the bun oh
my bad that's true the bun is very oh
yeah that's a front show we don't see
any buns she's two feet taller than me
no hair bun you dork oh admonish steven
for being wrong no yeah you're no you're
not admonish me well no you no i think
you you had the right to think that
buttons because why because why would
any logic
think that somebody would be that much
taller than the other person and they
still talk i know that one was granted
the winner you know what's bizarre to me
i don't know i have no explanation you
ever have something that just pops in
your head and you have no explanation
for your like i don't know why every
time i see elite bring it up bring it
bring that picture up for some reason
every time i see leah thomas i hear the
taco bell gong
i'd like to hear what an actual trans
person would have to say about this yeah
i would like to i think an actual i
think and any trans person would
probably agree that that's [ __ ]
pardon again sorry but i bet you that
i'm still really distraught over the
fact i don't know why i hear the taco
bell gone i think it's kind of battle
sorry i think it's kind of funny that
there were four women faster than the
man that was in the field
well he was holding back
so 200 is not his day's event
she should have won
[Music]
no that's not the taco bell bill it's
like
it's kind of like that poor girl to work
with what she has against a man for
crying out loud and she was missing an
ore do you know how i know the winner
should have to pay off aoc's debt
[Laughter]
we had a girl kicker on my football team
in grade school you were unnecessary
roughness she got smoked one time where
everyone just thought she's gonna die
yeah and she ended up being fine she was
a trooper but she shouldn't have been
out there yeah
they let my son seven so they do like
girls on the team yeah and like when you
got a girl out at first it's like
yay
yeah
who does he play for little giants yes
right yeah rick moranis is the coach
i had a weird dream about rick moranis
last night what i think it's because i
was reading on the hate crimes and then
it took me down a rabbit hole of rick
moranis being punched in new york city
but for some reason i had a dream that i
needed to hire him as a babysitter and i
was like well he's got to be a good one
i mean he shrunk the kids but he brought
him back got him back how did we have
the same dream
he's a problem solver had a great
adventure maybe it wasn't a dream at all
it just comes in here
uh is dinner snap there are they able to
were they able to go and talk with
anybody her tell her story
sorry he hasn't gotten back to me just
yet okay because i would love to hear
that i'm really curious and and you guys
can come by the way share
uh you know what if we get because we're
supposed to go to mug club
if there are 10 000 likes here in the
next five minutes we'll continue until
we get something more from gingersnap
live down there
uh because we're you know supposed to go
to mug club that's part of
our deal we need to warn him i think i
saw a ring so he needs to be nice what
not hit on this girl she has a ring i
think she has a ring i noticed that too
but it's probably because she doesn't
want to get hit on yeah i don't know
or she's not or she's she's not wearing
it when she swims because of the drag we
don't want him you need everything you
need every inch you can get when
competing against a man it must be lame
o'clock
how dare you
you're supposed to be magnum p.i man
what happened to you
really you should be suave no you told
me that i was the mortgage tom selleck
no no i'm just a douchebag well how do
you think you sell reverse mortgages
yeah it's housewives stupid you're the
avocado thomas yes yes the old people he
was the one stealing water from the dams
first avocado farm of course you know
how much water it takes to grow avocados
and he doesn't even like them well they
but they're worth money yeah so that's
why i do it and i steal your homes um do
we want to go to the secretary office of
diversity and inclusion i guess we'll
just keep going today it's kind of like
a live stream and we'll you know you let
me know if we hit those likes like i
said what did i said ten thousand likes
the next five minutes we'll continue
going because we like this is on the
ground we have no idea what's going to
happen maybe ginger snap gets punched by
the way uh find someone who will punch
ginger and maybe maybe he met his future
wife who knows maybe she look he's
trying to make up for it now hey yeah
yeah mr cockblock is now like hey who
knows it wasn't me so much as the
wedding ring that was the [ __ ] whatever
you're saying this thing yeah also uh
someone who thinks they're interested in
leah thomas is cocked blocked by a [ __ ]
sword blocks
being king arthur yes
that's got to be a thing now the only
worst [ __ ] block than gerald is chris
hanson
by the way that's a nicked apollo joke
just so you know because i don't want to
ever hear whatever
mr cockblock chris hanson has to come
over hey i have a secret minute
it was just women with penises
all right okay
so we'll move on to gingersnap once he
gets uh gets her in front of one of
those other lovely ladies because the
contrast won't be stark
the state department released this video
uh explaining its new twitter handle um
the secretary's office of diversity and
inclusion ah now just so you know this
is there's not a photoshop coming this
is not a joke
not a joke so ambassador gina
abercrombie with stanley
yes who looks like marv in home alone 2
after he tried to use the faucet that
was hooked up to a generator
explain the purpose
of this handle
secretary blinken made it clear in his
confirmation hearing that he would judge
the success of his tenure based on how
well he could build a state department
that reflects the rich diversity of our
nation our deia work rests on three
principles intentionality transparency
and accountability when it comes to
transparency we have established an
agency deia focus data team to provide
for the first time ever a detailed
picture of who we are as an organization
broken down by race gender disability
status employment category a grade rank
and job series it's about creating
incentives that reward those who advance
deia
as well as strengthen consequences for
those who discriminate harass or employ
bullying or other toxic management
practices in the workplace
when we advance transparency
accountability and accessibility for the
most underrepresented in our institution
this inherently creates a more equitable
meritocracy for everyone it's a win-win
for all if you just thought you just
heard a bunch of redundancies in
oxymorons like equitable meritocracy yes
equitability the way the left defines it
has to be uh mandated it has to be
orchestrated
she just said it categorized but it's
like you took a wish list of all the
things that stephen crowder hates as
qualifiers and put them in her mouth and
classified by race classified by gender
identity disability and she's just going
through a list and then saying it'll be
an equitable meritocracy well which is
it and then she wants to provide
incentives for the disabled is she she's
going to be dangling a carrot in front
of the guy with a wheelchair right do it
get up and walk i know it hi i'm the one
picture exactly what i was going to say
so i stepped on your phone you stepped
on your punch line with a picture
sometimes a picture's worth a thousand
jokes it's true yeah oh my gosh
this couldn't go wrong at all no and let
me again read the handle for you because
i can't go by the secretary's office of
diversity and inclusion george orwell
couldn't write it stupider
no they just said hi i'm here from the
office of the meek shall inherit the
earth yes yes
and she described the social credit
score and she said she was going to
gather data to grade intentionality
think about that for a second a social
credit score yeah hold on a second
a question let me ask a question here
for people who think that this sounds
good uh
how will this data be collected
how will it be used
could it be factored into promotions
could be factored into department
funding will someone be penalized for
being because she just named right
social class race gender uh identif did
she say orientation and gender she
didn't say orientation say orientation
gender identity or disability status job
classification so am i going to be
penalized for someone going to be
penalized for being a straight white guy
and by the way it's not like there isn't
a precedent that's been set for a social
credit system and no i'm not just
talking about that black mirror episode
that you all saw you know how it worked
for china right
china has a social credit system and
people can and are punished for things
like playing video games too long
wasting money
things like posts on social media and by
the way the punishments can be uh from
as like travel restrictions to being
barred from businesses and education to
being barred from certain regions like
that one guy who was a mixed martial
arts fighter who beat up all the old
kung fu masters
yeah and he was barred from travel yeah
barred from traffic for winning fights
you can have a bank account taken away
from you your social media posts if they
don't uh comply with what the regime is
saying they can be downgraded you can
have fewer friends in that circle if
you're a friend of somebody like that by
being their friend you can have actually
have your score lowered and so it really
further isolates these people it's
absolutely oiling you can have a strike
on your account basically for buying too
many video games not necessarily even
playing them look at all of what you
just said how will you know all those
things if the government is spying on
every single thing that you were doing
that's exactly what they're looking at
here right no that's i'm not saying if
i'm saying that's the only way to do it
and they're saying this is what we're
doing no i know what i'm saying they
already are our federal government is
just now saying the same thing we're
going to monitor every single thing that
you do and determine if you get
punishments
for not being inclusive enough or if you
get rewarded for being inclusive but
then we're going to have a meritocracy
so it doesn't matter how good you are if
you accidentally mispronounce somebody
yeah and by the way the that meritocracy
worked uh perfectly for leah thomas and
the woman who came in at the exact same
time but leah thomas got the trophy
instead well it's because she was a more
more uh you know group it's it's a
meritocracy it's a meritocracy well if
you buy that video game it's fine 2022
ea sports swimming yeah exactly you're
just balls on the cover your talent
points are just maxed out on strength
and speed leah thomas
[Laughter]
nobody else can even come close no it's
like you're constantly in street fighter
but in super turbo mode and nobody else
is
[Music]
because of the penis just to be clear
okay that's a callback here's another
question that i have while we're talking
about this because again these are ideas
that sound good inclusivity um how will
this emphasis on the inclusivity
actually for example affect what the
department actually does let's keep in
mind the state department it advises the
former vice president right now usually
presidents on foreign policy issues so
think about this do you think that do
you think that we'll be better off
in critical negotiations with china
if they depend on some diversity higher
they depend on some transgender
individual in a wheelchair
or at the very least a walker with a
parking brake on
how do how do you go it how does these
people from these departments or the
people who meet the qualifications of
these departments
women gays
trans whatever gender queer so many
look
we're here at 52 or at least we were at
52 genders on facebook i don't know how
many there are now could be more
in iran they're still at two
just to be they haven't even gotten to
really the third one you think we're
gonna go in there and have a negotiate
iran saudi arabia yemen
these aren't just hypotheticals here's
the problem this is the problem that we
are facing is when the theoretical of
academia you know right a place where no
one is actually held accountable for
what they teach because it doesn't work
when that permeates into the real world
unfortunately this is a lady from
academia who believes in modern gender
theory but that is going to be the basis
for hires for the people who will then
be our ambassadors for the people who
will then be involved in our
international deals and determine your
policy it's not just about a swim meet
do you see how all this ties back when
you break down the idea that there's
such thing as a man and a woman keep in
mind former vice president biden he's
gearing up right now to it for a trip to
saudi arabia to to beg to beg for oil
but by the way side note he won't meet
with the oil executives in his own
country by the way the ones he was
berating for the last week
yeah they're evil they're evil they need
to they need to sit down and shut up he
won't show up to meet with them but
he'll go over to bow to saudi princes so
that we can try and bring down gas
prices when we are the saudi arabia of
the world right now we just choose not
to be exactly with energy
by choice
and so there's again there's no
accountability and this is what
permeates the left it really is a theme
today and when people say classic
democrat so like let's say jfk that's
the democratic party before feminism
for feminism got a hold of it and i i
know but i'm really saying you go jfk
and then you go to okay jimmy carter
you go to obama you go to biden
right back then look at jfk jfk would be
considered a war hawk today
jfk would absolutely be considered a
republican today
it's not that they've both split to
extremes it's that the left has gone far
left and
the right has gone slightly left it's
just still that much of a split and then
you had feminism permeated and now you
have not only aoc
not only hirono never being held
accountable but that same mindset
infects the former vice president here
he is deflecting criticism uh from you
know his
and i say this this is allegedly poor
job
allegedly
but it's not his fault it's republicans
in crime in congress there you go
knowing full well the cost
so for all those republicans in congress
criticizing me today for high gas prices
in america are you now saying we were
wrong to support ukraine
are you saying we were wrong to stand up
to putin
are you saying that we would rather have
lower gas prices in america and putin's
iron fist in europe
i don't believe that
hmm
wait can we play that again
i'll just just just there so because i
wanted you to hear it for yourself
now let me play it again with my inner
monologue
knowing full well the cost
so for all those republicans in congress
criticizing me today yes for high gas
prices in america yes are you now saying
we were wrong to support ukraine yes
are you saying we were wrong to stand up
to putin very saying that we would
rather have lower gas prices in america
and putin's iron fist in europe yes
i don't believe that yes you're wrong
you're ladies the the the defense is
wrong it's unbelievable think about this
first hold on a second the iron fist of
putin they can't even take kiev i know
you're saying it's keiv now you're all
you can argue in the comments section
they can't even take a city that used to
be under their control the iron fist of
putin like they're gonna be marching
through all of europe doesn't mean that
i like putin
by the way where was this kind of like
hey guys we can't let putin get into uh
europe at all i mean that would be
terrible when he took crimea from
ukraine when you were in office right
vice president when you guys is is it
really that serious he ran on the ticket
with the guy who told mitt romney by the
way so that was not mccain romney in
2012 by the way uh uh uh the 80s called
they want their foreign policy back
right because he said to be aware of
russia and what they might do go to a
bath house you fake
does anybody bother that the leader of
the free world is slowly turning into
gary oldman and in hannibal yes
seriously pull up a picture it's the
right side of his face is like
deteriorating to the point that like no
he's way past that he's ray liotta
eating his own head yeah
well but well
well the brain's the same
this is delicious by the way he just
says he's just so you republicans who
want to yes let me explain to you why
okay we sent 54 billion about to you to
the ukraine when you total it up about
54 billion is what's been committed and
he says you republicans want to what you
think we shouldn't have gone in yes but
that's separate from the fact that
inflation was 1.4 percent right before
you took office to then 7.5 in a year
okay one year gas before the invasion
was 361.
the majority of the inflation the vast
majority of the inflation occurred
before russia and ukraine and the vast
majority well the vast majority of
inflation and certainly a majority of
gas prices the increase occurred before
russia and ukraine do you know how i
know do you know how i know do you know
how i know because we were bitching
about it long before anything happened
with the ukraine do you know how i know
that this election wasn't the most free
safe and secure in the history of this
country do you know how i know you know
how i know i know because with the most
watched election stream of any network
over 16 million people we experienced it
live in real time you can go and watch
it we were watching this and like okay
look wayne county they just called it
locally for uh for donald trump and then
two hours later we were live saying wait
a second
there's a 165 000
vote flip this was before there were any
amicus briefs before there were any
conspiracies we were just watching it
live covering it with you going
something seems really off here the same
thing here that's the value in doing
this day to day and being live
live day to day
you can see us talking about
the inflation that had already taken
place and the impending inflation coming
down the pike yeah well before russia
and ukraine yeah absolutely january
january was at seven and a half percent
so you're saying that's a good job mr
former vice president a six point one
percent increase in inflation when the
fed's job is to keep it at two percent
by the way treasury secretary powell
it's pretty funny it was before
yeah yeah
7.5 is a is a dream right now dave what
are you talking about baby it's eight
six yeah and by the way that's that's
what them manipulating the actual yeah
we know it's actually closer to 20. it's
going to go up a lot more for this come
on
not that high he's sitting before
congress or in the committee that he was
testifying before i think he's
testifying again today and he basically
said yeah that's not that's not true
biden lied yeah
he's uh he's got his facts wrong guys
you understand he's old and senile right
yeah the guy the guy the guy uh the fed
chair that you're talking about powell i
said this is so rough on buy and i have
to check he must have only gotten into
office uh donald trump no he was he was
put in put into place by barack obama
and then he was basically promoted by
donald trump ah
so he has two reasons to hate biden well
he's one he knows him and who he he
knows yeah exactly i really don't
understand how anybody can defend biden
or look at any of this administration
like it's okay the only people who do
left this one the only people the only
demographic left
white suburban woman not even black
people not even latinos not even if you
just average it out under the age of 30.
well i know a lot of white suburban
women that hate him oh of course of
course they do more swimmers yes of
course many of them do but that's the
only demographic right now that even
gives him a fighting chance
no one no one else is trying to defend
him and by the way i mean the kind of
white suburban women who silence other
white suburban women because they don't
want men competing in their sports it is
like we've talked about this if you look
at the demographics
under 30 percent for people under the
age of 30. we just covered those
yesterday it was 49 with black yeah
americans what what do you pull this up
really quickly dang it they pulled it
off so i want you to understand this so
this is the supreme court ruling that
we're talking about on guns and it said
on the lower third it said supreme court
expands gun rights for the first time in
whatever right in american history or
something like no they did not expand
gun rights the state of new york tried
to restrict exactly you being able to
carry a gun and having to show a need
for it the supreme court said no that's
not what the document says it's not
expanding gun rights right that's making
sure they're not infringed upon right
and they'll say that it's restricting
abortion access yes we're talking about
dobbs jackson right it's restricting
abortion access as though that's
what's so funny to me is when you have
the left where they'll say
so licensing isn't all struck down it's
just that you can't have this sort of
discretionary system i want a mini putt
through his tooth
a lot of gap tooth today the fire of
this opinion is this text history and
tradition only approach to figuring out
whether something's constitutional or
not and so i think what we can expect is
wait hold on a second hold on a second
the word is what did i just him say
constitutional or not
and
he continued to speak after that
without beating his own ass he said he
does it looks like he's saying they're
using text history and tradition to
determine whether something is
constitutional or not yeah which text
that would be the constitution um
what's history i don't know the guys who
wrote it saying what it meant yeah hmm
how it's traditionally been enforced and
interpreted hmm let's see what human
pair john king has to say how they
resisted the former president's effort
to ignore no no let's talk about january
6th let's talk about january 6. do you
want to know why because even with them
framing it the way that they are it's a
losing issue for democrats firearms are
a losing issue for democrats and they
know it and what's so funny we were just
talking about yesterday how they say
freedom's an illusion man and i told you
that actually security that safety is
really an illusion
well they also try and mock you if you
say there are god-given rights there's
new god give me man you actually believe
that they're in inalienable rights and
then they turn around and say you have
no right to my body
when they really mean another body a
body within your body with abortion
that's the only issue where for some
reason they fall back on this concept
that you have basic human rights that
are not given to you by government but
they believe should be protected by
government there is no right to an
abortion that's not a right that you
have okay there is absolutely a right in
this country in an alienable right to
keep and bear arms why because that's a
right to self-defense you have the right
to defend yourself and you know what you
may not like it you may not like it you
may prefer canada or the prime minister
just said canadians do not have the
right to self-defense with a firearm we
showed you that clip
pick one
but you do have to pick
you do have to pick you do have to pick
the country that recognizes any
inalienable rights that were granted to
you by god not even granted that were in
doubt you were endowed with them by your
creator
and the government recognizes it's funny
to me because it's not only people who
make this argument the government only
serves to recognize no the government's
only legitimate role it's only a
legitimate role it's one
is to protect those rights
that you were born with
that's why and you go oh okay so i have
these rights so what would be
government's role in protecting well a
military what do you mean to make sure
that other people don't come in and take
away those god-given rights
maybe some kind of police force to make
sure that your neighbor doesn't come in
and take your god-given rights
but that's the only legitimate function
of government they don't grant rights
and they can create nothing
they can only take from you
take from you and give to someone else
they can only so if they can only take
money let's be clear if the government
can really only take money okay we can
get into printing but let's be honest
that just devalues the money it's not
the same as a business providing goods
or services the government can't create
the government can only take right let's
look at that fiscally the same applies
to your rights
your government can't create rights
they can only take rights
and that's why you fight it every single
step of the way whether it's taking away
the right of a woman to compete
against other women
or the right of an eight-month viable
baby to be born or the right of you to
protect your house
whether you're in new york or in
california not a state issue or the
right for me to say that former vice
president joe biden is functionally
[ __ ]
and i think he's an embarrassment and no
one can stop me at every st and by the
way that includes you facebook youtube
twitter i know people say they're
private no no no no not when you're not
when you're regulated as a public public
utility
i can say what i want
let's be really clear about that got a
half asian lawyer on retainer who tells
me i can tells you i can and you know it
too
check your inbox this is why you fight
for the rights every single step of the
way not all right
we'll negotiate it's not a haggling
process
a compromise is a give and take
government can only take government
can't give government can't create all
right we are going to go to mug club and
continue with gingersnap and see if we
get uh down here at the turf war please
uh share like leave a comment below and
uh we'll uh we'll see you on monday piss
off youtube
[Music]